im Studio begrüße ich jetzt Norbert
Röttgen er ist CDU-Außenpolitiker und
Mitglied des Auswärtigen Ausschusses im
Bundestag schönen guten Morgen ein guten
Morgen die Vereinten Nation wollen
sollen für internationalen Frieden und
Sicherheit sorgen wie wichtig ist die so
Organisation eigentlich noch im
ukrainekrieg ist jetzt nicht als
Vermittlerin aufgetreten es gibt in
einerseits andererseits würde ich sagen
einerseits heute fängt die
Generalversammlung an vor dem Forum der
Welt wird das Unrecht des Krieges
angeklagt und das ist wichtig das ist
dafür Öffentlichkeit gibt das
Rechtsbruch und Unrecht und Krieg
angeprangert werden in die
Öffentlichkeit gebracht werden und Putin
kommt nicht kommt auch nicht also das
ist gut und auf der anderen Seite lähmt
ist das wichtigste Organ der Vereinten
Nationen in Sicherheitsrat dort gibt es
fünf wettomächte Russland China sind
zwei von diesen Fünfen und dieses
wichtigste Gremium ist gelähmt
paralysiert es kann nicht arbeiten und
darum ist auch die UN in dieser Frage am
Ende gelernt
jetzt haben elf Staaten unter anderem
Belarus Kuba Nordkorea und Syrien also
rund um Russland kurz vor Beginn einen
Brief verfasst in dem sie schon
angekündigt haben gewisse Beschlüsse der
UN-Vollversammlung zu boykottieren sie
haben es ja gerade auch schon ein
bisschen angedeutet wie gespalten ist
diese Institution also gut das sind
Syrien Nordkorea und andere sind die
sind Staaten sofern sie überhaupt noch
funktionierende Staaten sind die
das Recht sowieso nicht anerkennen die
Außenseiter sind und jetzt für sich ein
bisschen vielleicht die Chance als
Gruppe ich versuche nach einem Begriff
für diese für diese
Unrechtsstaaten die Außenseiter der
internationalen Gemeinschaft die halten
sich sowieso an nichts und dieser
Konflikt ist so dass auch viele immer
versuchen für sich daraus Vorteile zu
ziehen und die kommen jetzt sozusagen
als die Gauner Gauner ist noch zu
harmlos als die Verb rechergruppe der
internationalen Gemeinschaft zusammen
und versuchen für sich eine Rolle zu
finden ein eine Ausrede zu finden
internationales Recht nicht zu beachten
andere machen aus der aus den aus den
Energieblockaden ihre ziehen sie ihre
Vorteile indem sie billiger Energie
beziehen das ist ein Teil der Situation
wenn Krieg besteht gibt es auch
kriegsgewinner und solche werden welche
Rolle spielen die Länder des globalen
Südens
meine Meinung ist den globalen Süden
gibt es nicht was das ist Indien Sri
Lanka Argentinien Chile
Sierra Leone das ist nicht eine Einheit
aber wir haben eine wir haben sozusagen
eine Macht wir haben wir haben einen die
Macht ist zerbröckelt und es suchen sich
jetzt neue Macht Zentren und in dem
Konflikt zwischen China vor allen Dingen
und dem Westen das ist der eigentliche
Konflikt
suchen beide Seiten Verbündete alliierte
und der Westen war lange
ignorant auch arrogant und hat das China
überlassen und jetzt stellen wir fest in
der in der internationalen Politik zählt
wer hat die meisten Freundin Verbündete
darum holt man jetzt auf und diese
Gruppe von Staaten die man jetzt so
zusammenfasst wird darum auch macht
politisch wichtiger das ist der Kern der
Entwicklung es geht um weitere Hilfe für
die Ukraine die auch heute besprochen
wird unter anderem auch in Ramstein beim
Treffen der Ukraine Kontaktgruppe im
Fokus steht zum Beispiel auch die
Debatte und die Lieferung von Taurus
marschlu-körpern sie haben vor kurzem
gesagt sie finden es Zitat unverschämt
dass die Bundesregierung die Lieferung
nicht zusagt ist aber eine ordentliche
Prüfung und Sorgfältigkeit nicht geboten
absolut alles muss sorgfältig sein es
muss abgewogen werden nur da wird jetzt
ein halbes Jahr schon abgewogen und
darum halte ich das alles für Ausreden
und die Unverschämtheit sehe ich darin
wenn der Bundeskanzler sagt wir müssen
eine Reichweiten Verkürzungen dieses
effektiven Instrumentes das nur auf
ukrainischem Territorium gegen russische
Aggression eingesetzt wird wir müssen
eine Reichweiten Reduzierung
herbeiführen denn sonst könnte die
Ukraine weiter auf russisches
Territorium schießen die Ukraine tut das
seit 18 Monaten nicht sie versichert wir
tun das nicht wir wollen nur unser
eigenes Territorium
verteidigen und wenn dann immer noch und
immer noch der Ukraine die jeden Tag
Menschen verliert die angegriffen wird
der Ukraine Misstrauen geäußert wird
dann habe ich das so bezeichnet ich habe
dafür kein Verständnis die Ukraine
könnte deutlich weiter militärisch sein
wenn Sie diese diesen marsch-körper
bekommen hätte schon von einem halben
Jahr zum Schluss noch eine Frage zu der
Äußerung von Außenministerin Anna-Lena
bärburg im Vorfeld der Generaldebatte
hat sie den chinesischen Staatschef hier
als Diktator bezeichnet bezeichnet war
das unklug oder hat sie einfach die
Wahrheit gesagt beides inwiefern
es ist man muss dafür bezahlen es lohnt
sich nicht wenn Sie das als
Außenministerin macht und darum hätte
ich es ihr nicht geraten ich glaube es
mag auch im Überschwang eines englischen
Interviews gewesen sein dass diese
Formulierung gefallen ist es gab ja
schon mal so eine Situation wo sie auch
in dem englischen Interview gesagt hat
wir sind im Krieg mit Russland also das
man muss doch auch seine Worte
kontrollieren weil sie Außenministerin
ist dann hat es folgen und man muss für
solche Äußerungen dann in der Regel
immer etwas bezahlen das lohnt sich
nicht dann sollte man es besser sein
lassen
im Auswärtigen Ausschuss ganz herzlichen
Dank für das Gespräch